i'm not negotiating on those you
are willing to open it up so i can at
least see what's going on in your
country because i don't trust
dude i agree with you i'd love to see
that happen but there's no way they're
going to do that but then
we have to agree to do anything but
that's like saying how does that protect
america first
what do you mean how does that protect
america first that that makes you and i
be on equal playing field it's kind of
like it's kind of like this
so imagine you're bill belichick i am
pick another coach an nfl i don't know
what sport mike tomlin there you go are
you
which sport are you in are you a a uh
all of them okay let's just say
all of them and none of them at the same
time you're with pittsburgh
i'm bill belichick i'm with new england
patriots guess what
mike tomlin's games are televised i get
to see all the plays you call all the
audibles you call but guess what
patriots you can't play any kind of tv
when we play the hell we talking about
here
i got to be able to see when i'm doing
play-by-play and i'm saying look at the
receiver did this
how the hell am i going to know how
patriots plays defense i can't i can
play against you
because you're not doing a play-by-play
i'm doing play-by-play my name is
america china's not doing play-by-play
i can't see forget about
deflategate forget about spy gate
if china was a football team that'd
be spy gate on steroids
i mean what they're doing you can't see
nothing they're doing america's just
sitting there saying
it's just the way they are you have to
understand this is a cultural issue
patrick you don't understand i don't
understand i've lived in these
countries where i don't know i lived in
iran for 10 years when we had to be
quiet
but americans are just saying it's how
they are this is how you negotiate with
them
no standards values and principles
i'm held accountable you're held
accountable again i'm very comfortable
being wrong with this
i just disagree that if we're going to
negotiate you get to see my play-by-play
i kind of want to see your playback play
as well john
that's the ideal but i disagree with
your sports metaphor
because when the patriots play i don't
have volleyball analogy
it's not about the particular sport it's
that
the patriots either win or lose but you
defend business
and business only happens when it's
win-win
i buy a cup of coffee i give you the
book you show me the coffee we both have
this weird
you know i say thank you you say thank
you thank you thank you the double china
doesn't say thank you
right but yes they do
actually how do they say thank you they
give us
goods and in exchange we give them
pieces of paper with dead presidents
have you seen how many how many how much
money was made import export who made
more money who got the better end of the
deal you know it's like 4x more money
they make than we make
so what we get the better deal they get
pieces of paper
are you kidding me 80 of the world
pharmacy is being built over there if
they wanted to cut it off
we'd be dying today at the hospitals not
having a place to get our medication
they have created so much of a control
over us
what the hell are we going to do so
we've give no you you produce it you
produce it's cheaper you produce it you
produce it
now they're saying bam we got you and
80 and we're all going to die from
coffee or die number six
they're not going to corner the market
they have an incentive to sell us the
pharmaceuticals
and if it gets that dire control we'll
make a small amount of our own
you're libertarian we like freedom they
like control
okay they like control wheels you like
control sounds like you want to control
china i don't wanna it's not gonna
happen how is that control
minus control i wanna give the people
the freedom we have in america
freedom of press i want to know what the
hell is going on what part of my
argument is control
there's nothing i'm trying to control
china with you won't trade with them
unless they agree to certain principles
well they won't trade with us
unless we agree with certain principles
with them so isn't it like you got to
give some stuff up that i got to give
some stuff up in a negotiation you got
10 controls
the trade doesn't happen unless both
sides think they win well
they must be given guess what mr stossel
19 time emmy award winner going up
against the just a
red you know an entrepreneur here 1.8
gpa 1.8 gpa here's the challenge
that we face in this negotiation
we are so in too deep that we have
no leverage to negotiate with china
anymore we have to bow down today and
by the way if we don't stand ground now
10 20 30 years from now
they dictate what we do how do we bow
down to them are
how do we okay what are some of the
common
i'm i've got to get on a webinar here in
a minute but i'm going to say this to
you
what are the com what is the most basic
foundation of america
what is the most basic foundation of
america freedom individual liberty
okay individual liberty do you want to
have the people of china have that as
well
yes okay would that help us have a
little bit more accountability to know
what they're up to
yes would would you want to do business
with someone that's being a little bit
more transparent
or business with someone that's not
being transparent transparent if you and
i started a company together would you
be okay if i
you showed me your finances but i didn't
show you my finances are you okay with
that
no we have to have a common bookkeeping
right an accounting practice so we can
kind of talk about it
yes u.s is going into business with a
country that's not willing to share it
with you
and you're saying let's do it anyways so
look i got a request
i got an idea for you here's what i say
you and i do
i say you and i bring uh what's the
ladies them the chief disguise officer
from uh cia
john mendes we've interviewed interview
to perform from the white house i say we
bring her
she makes a disguise for you and i
and we go to china and we go become
detectives and we do a special episode
together me and you
finding out how how the people in china
feel
about their government how they live
there and let's test to see how far we
can go before we get arrested for six
months and unless documented me and you
let's create a channel together
john and patrick go to china what do you
think about that like bill and ted
i can't wait rick jones
it's a deal we're going to china and our
cameraman will be our buddy
right there i'll have a mustache so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]